Last time I sketched
the deprivation account.
That's a story or theory about what
it is about death that makes it bad.
What's bad about death is the fact that
because you're dead because you don't
exist, you're deprived of
the good things in life.
Being dead isn't intrinsically bad. It's
not like it's an unpleasant experience,
but it's,
it's comparatively bad.
You're worse off by virtue of the fact
that you're not getting the things that
you wouldn't get, where you're
still alive. If I'm dead,
I can't spend time with my loved ones.
I can't look at sunsets.
I can't listen to music.
I can't discuss philosophy.
The deprivation account says what's
bad about death is the fact that you're
deprived of the good things in life.
Now,
that seems pretty plausible
as a basic story goes,
but as we also saw last time,
there are some philosophical
puzzles about how it could be.
There's questions when
his deck bad for you,
and even more importantly
and more essentially there's
the difficulty of asking
ourselves,
do we really believe it's possible for
something to be bad for you when you
don't even exist?
We saw what kind of series of difficult
choices if we don't throw in an
existence requirement, if we don't
say it, put it more positively.
If we say things can be bad for you,
even if you don't exist at all,
then we're forced to say that
things are bad for Larry.
You'll recall that Larry was
our name for a potential person.
Somebody who could have come
into existence but never
actually does or will come
into existence. Well, you know,
it's talking about people who are
deprived of the good things in life.
Larry's completely deprived
of the good things in life.
If we think it doesn't matter whether or
not you exist for things to be bad for
you, then we have to say, oh, things
are bad for Larry and not just Larry,
but all of the 1.5 million
billion, billion, billion,
never to be born people.
The number of potential
people is just staggering,
and if we throw away in existence
requirement, we have to say it's a,
it's a moral tragedy of
unspeakable proportions that
these people are never born,
that they never come into existence.
Now,
there are philosophers who
are prepared to say that,
but if you're not prepared to say that
it looks as though you've got to accept
some kind of existence requirement.
You know,
why don't we feel sorry for Larry and
his billions upon billions of never to be
born compatriots because
indeed they don't exist.
They're merely possible and we might say
you got to exist in order for something
to be bad for you.
But once we say that,
it seems we're running towards
the position that in that case,
death can't be bad for me because of
course when I'm dead, I don't exist.
So how can you think me bad for me?
I proposed at the end of class last time
that we could try to solve this problem
by distinguishing between two
versions of the existence requirement,
a more modest version,
and the bolder version,
the bolder version says,
in order for something to be bad for you,
you got to exist at the very time
that it's happening. If we say that,
then indeed we can say it's not bad that
Larry doesn't exist because he doesn't
exist now.
So there's nothing there.
Even if we wanted to think that there
are good things he could be having that's
not bad for him to not have it and
he doesn't exist now, but it also,
if we go all the way to the of the bold
existence requirement, we have to say,
look, when I'm dead, that won't
be bad for me because, oh,
I won't exist then, but instead of
accepting the bold existence requirement,
we might settle for something
a little bit less demanding.
The thing I dubbed the
modest existence requirement,
in order for something to be bad for you,
there has to have been a time,
some time or the other when you exist,
you've got to,
as it were,
exists at least briefly in order to
get into the club as we might put it,
of those creatures,
those possible creatures that we care
about and are concerned about morally,
you have to have gotten into the club by
at least having existed for some period
of time,
but once you're in the club,
things can be bad for you even if you
don't happen to exist at that particular
moment. If we accept the
modest existence requirement,
then we can say it's not bad
that Larry doesn't exist because,
well,
Larry doesn't get into the club he had
in order to get into a club of things
that we feel sorry for,
you have to have existed at least
some moment of the other Larry and the
billions upon billions upon billions of
potential people who never actually come
into existence.
They don't satisfy the requirement of
having existed at some time or the other,
so we don't have to feel sorry for them,
but we can feel sorry for somebody who
died last week at the age of 10 because
we can say, well, they existed,
albeit very briefly,
and so they're in the club of beans that
we can feel sorry for and say, look,
it's bad for them that
they're not still alive.
Think of all the good things in life
they would be getting if they were still
alive.
So the modest existence requirement
allows us to avoid both extremes.
Maybe then that's the position
that we should accept.
It may be on balance.
The best possible view here,
but I just wanted to emphasize that even
the modest existence requirement is not
without its counter intuitive
implications. Consider somebody's life.
Suppose that somebody has got a
nice long life comes into existence,
leads,
lives 10 2030 405060708090 years.
Nice life.
Now imagine that we bring it about
that instead of living 90 years,
they have a somewhat shorter life.
10 2030 40 50 years.
We've caused them to die after 50 years
as opposed to the 90 years they might
have otherwise. Well, we
can say, look, that's,
that's worst for them to live nearly
50 years instead of the full 90 or 100
years.
Okay.
And if we accept the modest
existence requirement,
we can say that because after all,
whether you live 50 years or 90 years,
you did exist at some time and the other.
So the fact that you lost the 40 years
you otherwise would have gotten, well,
that's bad for you. Fair, fair enough.
That gives us the answer we want.
That's not counterintuitive. Now
imagine that instead of living 50 years,
the person who lives only 10
20 years and then dies, well,
that's more still think of all the extra
goods they would have gotten if only
they hadn't died then and if I caused
them to die after 20 years instead of 50
or 90 years,
I've made things worse and worse.
Imagine that I caused them
to die after one year.
We're still all this is perfectly
intuitive. The shorter their life,
the worst it is for them, the more they're
deprived of the good things in life.
So 90 year life, not bad, 50 year life,
worse 10 year life.
We're still one year life.
Worst still one month life,
worst still one day,
life worth Stitt worse.
Still one minute life worse.
Still one second life worse still.
Now imagine that I bring it about that
the person never comes into existence at
all. Oh, that's fine. See,
that's the implication of accepting
the modest existence requirement.
If I shortened the life,
they would have had so completely
that they never get born at all,
that they never come
into existence at all.
Then they don't satisfy the requirement
of having existed at some time or the
other.
So although we were making things worse
and worse and worse and worse and worse
as we shortened the life,
when we find the snip out that
last little fraction of a second,
it turns out we didn't
make things worse at all.
Now we haven't done
anything objectionable.
That's it seems what you got to say.
If you accept the modest
existence requirement,
of course if we didn't have an existence
requirement at all, we could say, oh,
worst of all, never to have
been born at all. Fair enough.
But if you say that,
then you've got to feel sorry for Larry.
You've got to feel sorry for the 1.5
million billion, billion, billions.
So which view is it
that on balance is the,
I don't want to say most plausible.
I think when we start
thinking about these puzzles,
every alternative seems
unattractive in its own way.
Maybe the most we can hope for is,
which is the least
implausible thing to say.
Here I am not altogether certain.
Let me turn to one more trouble or problem
or puzzle for the deprivation account
and this particular puzzle arises,
whether not we accept an
existence requirement,
whether or not we accept a bold existence
requirement or a modest distance
requirement or no existence requirement
because we've got a deal with somebody
who actually does exist
at some time or the other,
namely you or me.
This is actually a puzzle that some
of you may have written your paper on
because it's the puzzle about Lucretia.
The puzzle that Lucretia's gives us.
It's not a direct quote, but Lucretia
is basically says, look, most of us are,
are upset and anxious at the
fact that we're going to die.
We think death is bad for us.
There'll be this period after my
death in which I won't exist. And,
and, and the deprivation account
helps say why that's bad.
Because during this
period of nonexistence,
you're not enjoying the good
things in life. Fair enough.
Says Lucretia's but wait a minute.
The period after you die isn't the only
period during which you don't exist.
It's not the only period in which
if only you were still alive,
you could still be enjoying
the good things in life.
There's another period of nonexistence.
It's the period before my birth. I think
I've just switched the timeline here,
but all right, imagine this
is the period before my birth,
just like there'll be an infinite period
after my death in which I won't exist,
and realizing that fills us with
dismay. There wasn't, of course,
an infinite period before
I came into existence.
Well, if not existence is so bad
and by the deprivation account,
it seems that we want to say that it is.
Shouldn't I be upset at the fact that
there was this eternity before I was born,
but says, well, Kesha, you
know, that's silly, right?
Nobody's upset about the fact that there
was an eternity before they were born,
in which case it doesn't make any sense
to be upset about the eternity after you
die of nonexistence.
Well,
Lucretia's doesn't offer this as a puzzle.
Lucretia's offers this as an argument
that we should not be concerned about the
fact that we're going to die.
Most philosophers aren't willing to go
with Lucretia's all the way to the end of
the bus bus route.
Most Lucretia,
most most philosophers want to say
there's gotta be something wrong with that
argument someplace. There's
gotta be some. Well,
what are the possibilities here?
One possibility is indeed to just
agree with him. You're right.
Nothing bad about the
eternity before I was born,
so nothing bad of the
eternity of nonexistence,
so nothing bad about the eternity
of nonexistence after I die. Well,
that's one possibility to agree with
Lucretia's. Second possibility is to say,
look,
Lucretius you're right.
We really do need to treat these to
eternities of nonexistence on a par,
but we could turn it around instead of
saying with Lucretia's nothing bad about
this one.
So nothing bad about this one.
Maybe we should say instead something
bad about the one after we die and so
something bad about the
one before we were born.
Maybe we should just stick
to the deprivation account
and not lose faith in it.
The deprivation account says it's bad
that there's this period after we die
because we,
if we only we weren't dead,
then we would still be able to
enjoy the good things in life.
Maybe we should say look similarly then
when the deprivation account tells us
it's bad that there's this period
before we come into existence,
when we don't exist because
of only we had existed,
then we'd be able to enjoy
the good things in life.
Maybe Lucretia's was right.
We have to treat both periods the same,
but he's wrong in thinking we
shouldn't think either period is bad.
Maybe we should think both periods
are bad. Oh, that's a possibility.
What other possibilities? Are there
other possibilities to say, Lucretia?
You're right,
there are two periods of nonexistence,
but there's a justification
for treating them differently.
They're asymmetrical in a way that makes
sense from the point of view of what we
should care about.
Well,
it's easy to save that the puzzle that
most philosophers want to take that last
way out. They want to say.
There's something that
explains why it makes sense,
why it's reasonable to care about the
eternity of nonexistence after my death,
but where that doesn't apply to the
eternity of nonexistence before my birth,
and then the puzzle is to point to a
difference that would justify that kind of
rationally asymmetrical
treatment of the two periods.
It's easy to say it's okay.
It's reasonable to treat them differently.
The philosophical challenges to point
to something that explains or justifies
that.
Now a very common response is
to say something like this,
look,
consider the period after my death.
I'm no longer alive.
I have lost my life.
In contrast, the period before
my birth, although I'm not alive,
I have not lost my life.
I have never yet been alive,
and so of course you can't lose
something you've never yet had.
So what's worse,
this answer suggests about the period
after death is the fact that death
involves loss.
Whereas prenatal does not involve loss.
And so the conclusion comes and now we
see why it's okay to care more about that
one. Then this one, the one after
death than the one before birth.
Because the one after death involves
loss and the one before birth does not.
It's very,
very common response,
but I'm inclined to think that
can't be an adequate answer.
It's true of course,
that this period involves loss because
the very definition of loss is you don't
have something that at an
earlier time you did have.
So this period involves loss,
but the period before birth
does not involve loss.
Because although I don't have life, I
haven't previous to this period had life,
so I haven't lost anything.
Of course,
there's another thing that's true
about this prenatal period, two width,
I don't have life and I'm going to get it.
So I don't yet have something
that's going to come in the future.
That's not true about the post
life period. I've lost life,
but it's not true of this period that I
don't have life and I'm going to get it
in the future.
So this period involves loss,
interest in fat.
We don't have a name for this other
state where you don't yet have something
that you'll get later.
But you don't yet have it.
Let's call that not loss.
Let's call it Chammas.
Okay,
so during this period
there's a loss of life,
but no small slice of life and in
this period there's no loss of life,
but there's a small loss of life and
now we need to ask as philosophers,
why do we care more about loss
of life then Schmaltz of life.
What is it about the fact that we
don't have something that we use to,
that makes it worse then not having
something that we're going to,
yeah,
it's easy to overlook the symmetry here
because we've got this nice word loss
and we don't have this word smalls,
but that's not really explaining anything.
It's just pointing to the
thing that needs explaining.
Why do we care more about not having what?
Once upon a time we did,
then we care about not having what.
Once upon a time we will.
Well, there are some other
proposals that we might make.
A couple of them have actually been
sketched in some of your readings.
For example, Tom Nagel in his
essay on death says, look here.
Here's the difference.
It's easy enough to imagine and indeed
for their w for the actually be a
possibility of my living longer.
Suppose I die at the age of 80 and if I
didn't die then I'd continue living 90 a
hundred what have you there it is.
It's still me.
When you imagine me with an
earlier rather with you know,
living longer,
you're imagining me living longer
to use the vocabulary that we introduced
in thinking about some of Plato's
arguments we might say,
although it's supposed to,
I died at age 80 that's a fact about me.
It's a contingent fact about me.
It's not a necessary fact about me that
I died at 80 suppose at 80 I get hit by
a car, not unnecessary truth
about me that I got hit by a car.
I could have not gotten hit by a car
and live to the ripe old age of 90 or a
hundred when you die is not
an essential feature of you.
So it's easy for us to think about the
possibility in which I live longer but
says Nagel.
When I tried to imagine what would the
alternative be if I'm going to be upset
about the prenatal nonexistence we
have to imagine my being born earlier.
I was born in 1954 should I be upset
about the fact that you know, I,
I was born in 1954 instead of 1944 I mean
that's the analog of being upset about
the fact that I dying whatever it is,
you know,
2044 instead of living to 2054
natal says,
but look,
when you try to think about
the possibility in which
instead of being born in
1954 I was born in 1944 and
four. You know, the rest of you,
you got to sort of plug in your own
birth dates. Nagle says you can't do it.
The date of my death is a
contingent fact about me,
but the date of my birth is not a
contingent fact about me and my birth.
We don't really mean, you
know, when I came out of the
womb that could be changed,
you know, perhaps by having been
delivered prematurely or who says area.
And what have you really mean that the
time at which I come into existence,
let's suppose it's the time
when the egg and the sperm join.
That's not a contingent
moment in my story.
That's an essential
moment in my life story.
How could that be?
We said,
couldn't my parents have had sex earlier
10 years earlier? Sure they could have,
but remember if they had
had sex 10 years earlier,
it would've been a different egg and
in different sperm coming together,
so it wouldn't be me.
It would be some sibling of mine
that as it happens, never got born,
but it had,
they had sex 10 years earlier.
Some sibling would have been born.
That's not me being born earlier.
Different sperm, different egg
makes for a different person.
So you can't, you can, you can save the
words if only I'd been born earlier,
but it's not actually
metaphysically possible. Well,
it's an intriguing suggestion but I
think it can't quite be right or at very
least it can't be the complete
story about how to answer.
Lucretia says puzzle as suppose as we've
got a fertility clinic that has some
sperm and on on hold and
has some eggs on hold,
you know in the, in the sperm
bank and the and the egg bank,
what have you and they keep them here,
you know,
frozen until they're ready to use them
and they thaw them out in whatever it is,
2020 and then the person's born,
of course he could go back,
he could look back and say if only they
had put my sperm and egg together 10
years earlier, that would still
be me after all, very same sperm.
Very same egg makes for
the very same person.
So if only they had combined my
sperm and egg 10 years earlier,
I would have been born 10 years earlier.
Well,
so Nagle's wrong and saying it's not
possible to imagine being born earlier in
at least some cases it is. Yet,
if we imagine somebody like that,
somebody who's an offspring of this
kind of fertility clinic and we ask,
would they be upset that they
weren't born earlier? No.
Again still seems as though most
people say no, of course not.
So the Nagel answer doesn't seem
to me to be an adequate one. Well,
there's another possible answer.
This is Fred Feldman's answer also in
one of the papers that you've read,
Fred Feldman says,
Nagle's a contemporary philosopher for it.
Feldman's and contemporary philosopher
Feldman says, when I imagine, you know,
suppose I get killed by the busing in
2044 and if I imagine if only I hadn't
died,
then what is it that we imagine we imagine
instead of living 80 years living 90
or 95 or more,
we imagine a longer life.
But what is it that happens when I
say if only I'd been born earlier,
well says Feldman,
you don't actually imagine a longer life.
You just shift the entire life
and started earlier. I mean,
after all supposedly just said,
especially if I'd asked you this
question before setting all this up,
but if only you had been born in 1800
nobody thinks, oh, if only I'd been
born in 1800 I'd still be alive. I'd be,
you know, 200 years old. You Think, Oh, if
I'd been born in 1800 I would have died,
you know,
86018701880 whatever it is.
When we imagine being born earlier,
we don't imagine a longer life,
nothing better about having a life earlier
according to the deprivation account.
But when we imagine not
dying when we actually die,
who say if only I died in 2015 instead
of 2040 it's not that we imagined having
been born later.
We don't shift the life forward.
We imagine a longer life.
So Feldman says no wonder,
no surprise that you care about
the non existence after death.
Because when you imagine that being
different, you imagine a longer life.
But when you start thinking about the
nonexistence before birth and you imagine
that being different,
you don't imagine more goods in life,
you just imagine them taking
place at a different time.
Well that's an interesting possibility,
I suppose.
Doesn't seem to me again that
it's gotta be, it's gotta be,
maybe it's part of the story.
It doesn't seem like it's
going to be the complete story.
Yeah.
Because we could imagine cases
where the person just thinks, look,
if only I'd been born earlier,
I would have had a longer life.
Let's suppose that next week
astronomers discover the horrible fact.
If there's an asteroid that's about to
land on the earth and wipe out all life.
Yeah.
So here it is. You know, it's
got to come on January 1st,
2008 and, and there you are at
whatever your age is, you know,
20 years old,
21 years old on January and December 31st,
2008 thinking I've only
had 20 years of life.
If only I'd been born earlier,
if onlys that have been born,
you know, whenever it was,
I had been born 10 years earlier,
I would have had 30 years of
life instead of 20 years of life.
That seems perfectly intelligible.
So it does seem as though
if we put our head into it,
we can get ourselves into thought
experiments where we say, yeah,
don't just ship the life,
make it longer.
But instead of making it longer
in the post death direction,
make it longer in the pre birth direction.
Well,
again, you can imagine somebody
saying, yeah, and when we do that,
we should feel the same.
W you know,
it doesn't really matter
which direction it goes.
So symmetry is the right
answer after all wouldn't date.
When I think about the asteroid
example, I find myself thinking, Huh,
maybe symmetry is the right way to
way to go here. Maybe Feldman's right?
That normally we just shift instead of
extending. But if I'm careful to extend,
maybe that really is bad that I didn't
get started sooner and have a longer life
in that direction.
Well,
here's one other answer
that's been proposed.
This is by yet another contemporary
philosopher, Derek Parfitt. Parfitt says,
it's true that when I think about
the nonexistence after I die,
that's loss.
Whereas the nonexistence I'm born,
that's not lost,
that's near Schmall sauce.
And it's true that we need an explanation
about why loss is worse than small Os.
But we can see that this is not an
arbitrary preference on our part
because in fact it's part
of a quite general pattern
we have of caring about the
future in a way that we
don't care about the past.
This is a very deep
fact about human caring.
We are oriented towards the future and
concerned about what happens in it in a
way that we're not oriented and concerned
about what happened in the past.
Perfect. Got a very nice example to
sort of bring the point home. He says,
imagine that you've got
some sort of a conditioned,
some sort of medical condition that will
kill you unless you have an operation.
So fair or not,
if you're going to have the operation,
this will allow you to live your life.
Unfortunately,
in order to perform the operation,
they can't have you anesthetized.
You have to be awake perhaps in
order to, uh, tell the surgeon. Yeah,
that's where it hurts.
You know, whatever it is,
sort of like when the dentist pokes
and says, you know, does this hurt?
Does that hurt?
So you've got to be awake during the
operation and it's a very painful
operation.
Can't give you a painkiller because then
you won't be able to point out it does
this hurt,
does that hurt and so forth and so on.
Since we can't give you painkiller, all
we can do is this after the, so you'll,
you'll be awake during this
basically being tortured.
You'll be awake being tortured.
It's still worth doing it because this
will cure the condition and then you'll
have a nice long life.
Since we can't give you painkillers sends,
we can't put you out. All we're going to
do is, but we, what we will do is this,
after the operation is over,
we'll give you this very powerful
medication which will give you short term.
It's sort of very localized amnesia.
You won't remember anything
about the operation itself,
so you won't have to at least to dwell
upon these horrible memories of having
been tortured. Those will be completely
wiped out. Okay, so painful operation.
You're awake during it.
After the operation,
you're given this thing that makes you
forget whether you've had the operation,
you know anything about the operation
at all. The preceding 24 hours,
we'll be completely wiped out.
So you're in the hospital, uh,
and you wake up and you ask yourself,
have I had the operation yet?
Or not? Don't know. Right.
Because of course if I haven't had it,
no wonder I don't remember it.
But if I had had it,
I would've been given that
temporary sort of localized amnesia.
So of course I wouldn't know whether or
not I've had it. So you asked the nurse,
have I had the operation yet
or not? She says, I don't know.
We have a couple people on the,
on the hall today who are,
some of them have had it and some of
whom are hat I was scheduled to have it
later today.
I don't remember which one you are.
Let me go look at your file.
I'll come back and I'll tell you.
So she's wanders off. She's going to
come back in a minute or two. And as,
as you're waiting for her to come back,
you ask yourself,
what do you want the answer to be?
Are you indifferent or do you care
whether you're one of the people who's
already had it or somebody
who hasn't yet had it.
Now if you're like Parfitt and for that
matter like me, then you're going to say,
of course I care.
I want it to be the case that I,
one of the people who's
already had the operation.
I don't want to be one of the people who
hasn't yet had the operation might say,
how can that make any sense?
Your life's going to have the operation
sooner or later at some point in your
history,
life history,
that operation is going to have occurred
and so there's the same amount of pain
and torture regardless of whether you're
one of the people that had it yesterday
or one of the people.
It's going to have it tomorrow,
but for all that says Parfitt the fact
of the matter is perfectly plain that we
do care.
We want the pain to be in the past.
We don't want the pain
to be in the future.
We care more about what's happening in
the future than we care about what's
happening in the past.
That being the case,
no surprise.
We care about the nonexistence in the
future in a way we don't care about the
nonexistence in the past.
Well,
that may be right as
far as explanation goes,
but we might still wonder whether or
not it's any kind of justification.
The fact that we've got this deep seeded,
asymmetrical attitude towards time doesn't
in any way as far as I can see yet.
Tell us whether or not
that's a justified attitude.
Maybe evolution built us to care about
the future in a way that we don't care
about the past and it
shows up in lots of places,
including parfaits hospital case,
including our attitude towards loss
versus small costs and so forth and so on.
But the fact that we've got this attitude
doesn't yet show that it's a rational
attitude. How could we show that
it's a rational attitude? Well,
maybe we'd have to start doing some
heavy duty metaphysics if what we've been
doing all so far.
It hasn't yet heavy duty enough.
Maybe we need to talk about the difference
between the metaphysical difference
between the past and the future.
The past is fixed.
The future is open,
the direction of time.
Maybe somehow we can bring all of these
things in and explain why our attitudes
towards time make sense.
I'm not going to go there.
All I want to say is it's not altogether
obvious what the best answer to
Lucretia pieces puzzle is.
So when I say,
as I had said,
and I'm going to say it many times
over the course of the remaining weeks,
that the central thing that's bad about
death is the fact that you're deprived
of the good things in
life. When I, when I,
when I make use of the
deprivation account,
I don't mean to suggest everything is
sweetness and light with regard to the
deprivation of cod,
I think there are some residual puzzles
about how it could be that death is bad
and in particular how it could be that
the deprivation of comp puts its finger
on what's bad about death.
But for all that,
it seems to me the right way to go.
It seems to me that the deprivation of
cow does put its finger on the central
bad thing about death most centrally.
What's bad about death
is that when you're dead,
you're not experiencing
the good things in life.
Death is bad view because you don't have
what life would bring you if only you
hadn't died. All right. If that's right.
Should we conclude?
In fact,
do we have to conclude if death is
bad because of it's a deprivation,
then if I wasn't dead,
I wouldn't be deprived.
So doesn't it follow then that the best
thing of all is never to die at all to
it in mortality?
If it's bad,
you're supposed to get hit by
a truck next week. That's bad.
Because if only I hadn't
gotten hit by a truck,
I might've lived another 2030 years,
whatever.
We've gotten the good things in life,
that would have been better for me. Ah,
but when I die, whatever it is, you know,
some heart disease at age 80 that's bad
for me because of only they didn't have
heart disease. I could have
lived another 10 15, 20 years,
gotten more good things in life.
If only I hadn't died at a hundred
would've gotten more good things in life,
only hadn't died at 500 would have
gotten more thing. Good things in life.
Whenever it is,
I die.
Won't it always be true if we accept
the deprivation account that if only I
hadn't died then I would've
gotten more good things in life.
And so whenever it is you die,
death is bad for you.
So the best thing for you would
be never to die in mortality.
Yeah.
Two questions really that we need to ask.
One is,
does consistency,
does logic require somebody who
accepts the deprivation account?
Does consistency required that if
you accept the deprivation account,
you believe in mortality is a good thing?
Yeah.
Second question.
Even if logic doesn't require that,
is it true that immortality
is a good thing?
Let me start with the first one cause I
think that's the easier one. Logic alone,
logic plus the consistency
requirement could either the uh, uh,
deprivation couch logic alone doesn't
require us to say mortality is a good
thing.
Why?
Because strictly speaking what
the deprivation accounts says,
his death is bad in so far as you're
deprived of the good things in life by
virtue of not existing,
if only hadn't got hit by that truck,
you would have gone onto an exciting life,
has your career as a professional dancer,
he would've had a family what happened,
whatever it is,
you would have traveled around the world
like it would've given you a lot of
great things and you get
deprived of those great things.
That's why it's bad that
you got hit by the truck.
That is to say death is bad when it's bad
by virtue of the fact that it deprives
you of the good things in life,
but suppose we don't yet know
whether this could actually happen,
but he'll just talking
about logical possibilities.
Suppose that there is no more
good things for life to give you.
Then when you're deprived
of life by death,
you're not being deprived of any good
things and so it's not bad for you to be
dead at that point.
Death is only bad according
to the deprivation account.
When there are good things that would
have come your way. When I was new,
I put it on balance.
The life you would have had would
have continued to be good for you.
When that happens,
then to lose that good bit of life,
that's bad for you.
But if it should turn out that what life
would have had here after instead of
being good would have been hellish.
It's not bad for you to avoid.
That might actually be
good for you to avoid it.
So even if we accept
the deprivation account,
we're not committed to the
claim that death is always bad.
We have to look and see what would
life actually hold out for us.
Logic alone plus the deprivation account
doesn't force us to say in mortality
would be a good thing.
After all,
this is really a crucial point to
understand things that are good for you in
limited quantities can become bad for
you if you get more and more and more and
more of them.
But I love chocolate.
So I suppose somebody comes up to me with
a box of Godiva chocolate offers me a
couple of chocolates and say,
wonderful,
I loved the dive of chocolate and then
you give me some more and some more 20
pieces of chocolate. Well, you know by
the time I got 20 pieces of talking about,
I'm not sure right now I
really want the 21st piece,
but you keep giving me some more 30 pieces
of chocolate, 40 pieces of chocolate,
a hundred pieces of
chocolate at some point. Not,
never act actually had as much talk.
I don't know what the point is,
but at some point I'm going to say,
you know,
although the first 10 2030 pieces
of chocolate, those were good,
but giving me the 21st piece of
chocolate or the 50th piece of chocolate,
no longer good.
Logically,
at least it could happen logically.
It could happen that although
in quantities, small quantities,
50 years, 60 years, a
hundred years, life is good.
At some point maybe life
would turn bad for us.
Just like being forced fed
more and more chocolate,
and if it didn't turn bad for us, the
deprivation account would allow us to say,
Oh,
at that point dying is not bad for you.
Well,
that's all that logic tells us.
Logic simply tells us we don't have to
believe in mortality is a good thing,
but for all that it could still be a good
thing. So that's question number two.
Let's ask,
what should we think about the
prospect of living forever?
Would in fact be better and
better and better? You know,
somebody dies at age 10
by some horrible disease,
better if they'd made it up to 40 somebody
dies at age 40 better if they made it
up to 80 somebody dies.
They pay at age 80 better if they made
it to a hundred 120 is it true that life
would get better and better
and better the longer it is?
Yeah.
Now in asking this question,
we have to be careful to be clear
about what exactly we're imagining.
Here's one way to try
to imagine that story.
Imagine that life is sort of
the way it works now with you.
So kind of the kinds of changes that
bodies undergo as they get older,
but instead of sort of those changes
basically killing you at 80 90 or a
hundred, they don't, you get
more and more of those changes,
but they never actually kill you.
Okay.
This is the thought sort of
thought experiment that, uh,
Jonathan Swift undertakes in the passage
from Gulliver's travels that I've had
you look at,
he imagines Gulliver coming to a country
where a subset of the people live
forever immortals. And at first
Gulf says, oh, isn't this wonderful?
But he forgot to think about the fact
that if the kinds of changes that we
undergo continue to accumulate,
then you're getting older,
not just older,
but weaker in more and more discomfort.
Senility sets in with a vengeance until
eventually you've got these creatures
that live forever,
but their mind is gone and they're sort
of in pain and they can't do anything
because their bodies utterly
infirmed and diseased and sick.
That's not a wonderful thing to have.
If in mortality was that says swift,
that would be horrible for
an immortality like that.
Death would be a blessing.
And Montana in the essay that
I've had you look at says indeed
death is a blessing because it puts an
end to the pain and suffering and misery
that afflict us in our old age.
Well all of that seems right,
but I suppose we'd be forgiven by.
Thank you for thinking.
Look when we want it to be a mortal,
we didn't want this kind of life
going on and on and on with the same
trajectory,
the same downward trajectory.
We sort of want it to live forever.
Hale and hearty and healthy.
So even if the real world
wouldn't allow us that,
let's just ask science fictiony whether
or not in fact living forever would be
good. Isn't it? At least
true that in principle,
living forever could be good.
You got you gotta imagine sort of changing
some of the facts about what it would
be like to live forever.
So instead of asking the question,
the question I started with,
you know,
would it be good to live
forever if you're not careful?
This is going to be one like one
of those horror stories, right?
Where the where the what you will.
You've got a couple of wishes, you know,
and you weren't careful about how exactly
you state the wish and so you get what
you want, but it ends up
being a nightmare, right? If
you just tell the, you know,
the, the ferry, I want a, you
know, it gives you three wishes.
I want to live forever and you forgot
to say and be sure to keep me healthy.
Well, that's going to be a
nightmare. That's what swift
told us. So let's, let's,
let's be careful.
Let's throw in health and
anything else you want. Throw it.
Throw in enough money to make
sure you're not poor for eternity.
Wouldn't that be horrible to be
healthy but impoverished forever?
Throw in whatever you want.
All we need to ask at this point is,
is there any way at all
to imagine in mortality?
We're in mortality of that
sword would be a good thing.
Is there any way to imagine existing
forever or that would be good for you
forever. Now it's very
tempting at this point to say,
look,
of course nothing could be easier.
Just imagine being in heaven forever,
right? You're done, right? You got
heavenly bliss. Isn't this incredible?
When we all love to be in heaven forever?
The trouble is we were a little bit
vague about what exactly life is like in
heaven.
It's,
it's a striking fact that even
those religions that promise us,
you know, an eternity in
heaven are rather shy on the
why because one might worry if you
actually tried to fill in the details,
this wonderful eternal existence ends
up not seeming so wonderful after all.
So, you know, imagine that what's
going to happen is that, you know,
we all become angels and we've gone
to spend eternity singing psalms.
Now I like psalms and I actually enjoy it.
Rather it's singing psalms
at services. I, I, uh,
on Saturday mornings I sing psalms
in Hebrew and I rather enjoy it. Uh,
but if you ask me what about the
possibility of an eternity of doing that,
that doesn't really seem so desirable?
Uh,
um, the dazzled, uh, not, not the remake,
haven't seen the remake, but the original,
uh, in, in the original,
um, uh, there's a,
a human character who hooks up
with, uh, uh, the, the devil.
And he asked the DEA meat's
the devil and ask the devil,
so why did you rebel against God? And the
devil says, well, I'll show you. You know,
you sit here on the, on whatever
it was, the, um, uh, a mailbox,
I think it was, uh, um, uh, I'll set
up here in the mailbox. The devil says,
and you dance around me and say, oh,
praise the Lord. Aren't you wonderful?
You are so magnificent. You so glorious.
And the human does this for a while.
And he says, this has gotten
really boring. Can't we
switch? And the devil says,
that's exactly what I said.
Now when you try to imagine heaven
singing psalms for eternity,
that doesn't seem so attractive.
All right,
so don't imagine heaven
singing psalms for eternity.
Just imagine something else.
But what?
Imagine what,
this is sort of the thought experiment
that I invite you to participate in.
What kind of life can you imagine such
that having that life forever would be
good, not just for another 10 years,
not just for another hundred years,
not just for another thousand years
or a million years or a billion years.
Remember eternity is a very,
very long time.
Forever goes on forever.
Can you describe an existence that you
would want to be stuck with forever?
Now,
it's precisely at this point that Bernard
Williams and another one had papers
that are had you take a look at burden.
Williams says no.
No kind of life would be one that would
be desirable and attractive forever.
No kind of life at all.
In short says Williams,
every life would eventually
become tedious and worse.
Excrutiatingly painful.
Every kind of life is a life you
would eventually want to be rid of.
Immortality far from being a wonderful
thing would be a horrible thing.
Suppose for the moment that we
were to agree with Williams,
what then should we say? We might say,
look, at least when we're being careful.
If we agree that in
mortality would be bad,
we can't say then that
death per se is bad.
The very fact that I am going to die,
it turns out not to be a
bad thing because after all,
the only alternative to
dying is in mortality and if
in mortality would be a bad
thing, then death is not a bad
thing. Death is a good thing.
We might say if we accept Williams's
thought the fact of our mortality is good
rather than bad,
if in mortality would eventually be bad.
Now of course crucial to notice
that even if we say this,
that doesn't mean that when you get
hit by a car tomorrow that that's good.
You don't have to say that.
You can still say it's a bad thing that
I got hit by a car tomorrow because
after all,
if I hadn't gotten hit by a car tomorrow,
it's not as though I would have
then been condemned in mortality.
I just would have lived another 10 or 20
or 30 years and those years would have
been good ones for me and
maybe even when I die.
Let's suppose I lived to the ripe old age
of 100 when I die at a hundred I could
perhaps still say it's a bad thing for
me that I die at the age of a hundred
because if I hadn't died now,
I might've lived another 10 2030
years and still enjoy things in life,
enjoy playing with my great grandchildren,
whatever it is.
To save it in mortality is bad,
is not to say it's a good
thing that we die when we do.
You can still believe consistency
consistently that we die too soon.
Even if in principle,
eventually, sooner or later,
death would no longer be bad.
It could be that it comes
too soon for all of us still.
The question we want to ask is,
is there any way even to imagine an
immortal life that will be worth having in
principle, could immortality be a good
thing or is Williams right that no,
even in principle goal is fantastic and
science fiction is you want in principle
and a mortal life could not be desirable.
So until next time I invite you
to to think that question through.
If you're attracted to the
prospect of immortality,
what would the best kind
of immortal life be like?